people assume that you're stoned yeah  yeah yeah that's fair to say yeah all  the time that's one small guitar guitar  was like yeah no I just yeah it's it's  it's threefold I suppose it's it's my  thus worthier aspects of my heritage  that when I when I get anxious I can  kind of close up my eyes and it keeps  the world out a bit and I'm just super  photosensitive and so whenever I read  all this stuff of like oh look how high  he is on that TV show and this and that  and I'm like I could have been high I  messed up anyways I have a work ethic so  I'm completely you could eat off me guys  and that's that's that's  oh please eat off me oh stop it  like a bonsai tree no stop it  you show down a little Tokyo we all  longer in  [Laughter]  you